uh yep we're going here hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by bougie
bakes and we'll be taking a look at
ballerina theresa farrell and why she
counts calories to prepare for her
ballet season
this was a highly requested video ever
since i posted my review of
scout fourth size video which you can
watch right here
since ultimately the two dancers could
not be
more different in their approach to food
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor
bougie bags so now that the world is
finally starting to open up a bit
i'm really trying to enjoy the summer
and try entertaining outside as much as
i can
so i'm having friends over for brunch at
least once a week now
and you guys know me i have zero qualms
about
indulging in full sugar full gluten full
dairy
and all the things but most of the
families that i host
have at least one or two different
dietary restrictions so
i tend to have to kind of get creative
especially when it comes to dessert
so i'm always so grateful when i can
find something sweet
that i don't have to make from scratch
that is ultimately a really safe bet for
all of my friends regardless of their
dietary goals
so these sweets are from bougie bakes
all of their desserts are completely
gluten-free dairy-free
and sugar-free for the folks watching
blood sugars and they also have a
wide variety of vegan options too
naturally this means that i like to
serve mine with like a lot of full fat
full sugar full dairy ice cream but
again
i'm all about choice i'm also not
somebody who would
knowingly choose like a sugar-free
cookie
like ever but they are actually
really good so i don't feel like i'm
giving my friends and family
something that i wouldn't want to eat
myself they also deliver
fresh to your door so it's really just
one less thing on your plate
and i like that they use these great 100
recyclable and reusable packages
in all their orders so if you want to
learn more you can check out my link
in the description and use my promo code
abby20
to get 20 off of your order also you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a huge trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating
as i will of course be talking a lot
about numbers and
calories and of course don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode
so in this video teresa gives us a
behind-the-scenes look
at how she prepares for her season with
the american contemporary ballet in los
angeles by working towards a goal to
lose
weight now in order to get there she's
attempting to drop about a half a pound
a week
through pretty precise calorie counting
now since i'm not a sports dietitian
myself
i reached out to some of my colleagues
two of which actually work full-time
with ballerinas so i want to say a huge
thank you to
heidi skolnik yassy ansari chelsea cross
and ali coogler for weighing in and
giving me some
great insight through their clinical
experience and on that note
let's take a look at what this ballerina
eats in a day
so i am 115 and a half pounds
and i feel i dance my strongest at 114
pounds
because i think i've heard this with
cyclists
you want as much lean muscle as you can
so you can propel
up the hill as quickly as possible so
first of all
i want to approach this sensitively and
with kindness because
while a lot of us may see a woman like
teresa
and scoff at her desire to lose weight
it's important to note that
these unattainable standards are very
much
rooted in the culture of dance research
actually suggests that
female ballet dancers tend to have the
lowest
body weight when compared to other forms
of dancers
which also speaks to why there's such a
high prevalence of disordered eating
among ballet dancers in the pursuit of
thinness now i'm not about to make any
assumptions
about teresa but i did just want to be
empathetic here
because there is a lot of internal
pressure and expectation around physique
in the dance culture itself as for her
goal to lose weight
i think it's important for me to just
point out that i do believe strongly in
body autonomy and that ultimately you've
got the right to
want to change your body but if you're
my client
i would want to really be discussing
some of the potential risks
of further weight loss when there are
some
clear risks associated with that goal
which i'm going to speak to more
in a bit as you know i hate bmi
and we also know that it's not the best
indicator of health especially for folks
in
the overweight category but we do have
evidence that being severely underweight
does appear to increase the risk of
all-cause mortality
even more so than with severe obesity so
at 115.5 pounds
theresa is already considered
underweight at a bmi of
18.1 and losing that precious pound and
a half
will put her at a bmi of 17.9
this may feel good to her and where she
dances her best
but it's generally not the direction
that we would want to head towards
for improved health and i'd be trying to
really
unpack and explore that experience with
her in more detail
if she was my client now again this is
nuanced
and these bmi goals are really just
averages
and not particularly great ones so the
bigger question for me would be around
body fat percentage to sustain hormonal
function now
obviously i'm not teresa's doctor i
don't know anything about her hormonal
health
but i will just warn that most folks
need to maintain a
body fat percentage of around 22
to maintain regular menstrual cycles and
most women don't see abs until they are
well under the 20
body fat mark hence why getting super
lean or like a six pack
isn't necessarily the most healthy
sustainable goal
i also want to point out that with any
weight loss there is
a big risk of losing metabolic muscle
mass
which it sounds like is not something
that
teresa would want but anyways i want to
get into looking at the food so
let's take a look what she has for
breakfast i've been training to get back
to my performance weight
i am going to eat a pre-breakfast
so i like to have a corn dog
first thing in the morning these are
actually really delicious
and really filling and i don't think
it's actually that unhealthy
that i'll eat while i do my stretches
so i get these stuffed peppers with
turkey
and rice and so it's 2 40 for one of
them
alrighty so teresa starts her day off
with a
corn dog as her pre-breakfast followed
by what looks like a frozen dinner of
stuffed peppers with some turkey and
rice
i mean this obviously doesn't read as a
typical breakfast meal
but i also guess it's kind of refreshing
to not see like a smoothie bowl
or avocado toast as usual now the key
here
for something like a rehearsal day would
be to make sure we're fueling up with
some
good carbs and some protein to help
sustain practice
and it does sound like that's what
theresa's goal is as well
so in this case we have carbs fat and
protein
in the turkey and rice stuffed pepper
and corn dog and a little bit of veggie
action
from the peppers as well now this is a
higher sodium meal
but in terms of a meal for you know
pre-rehearsal
as unconventional as it might be it's
not a bad choice
i would probably want to see a little
more carbs here to really get her
through
a really long rehearsal day but that
could really be
as easy and convenient as just adding in
one or two pieces of fruit other fast
and convenient options
might be to do like an egg and cheese
wrap with a bowl of fruit
or a solid bowl of oatmeal with some
raisins fruit
and a couple hard-boiled eggs i do
however want to comment on teresa's
suggestion
that she didn't think these corn dogs
were that unhealthy
and i mean ultimately i agree i
appreciate that theresa
isn't demonizing food here even a food
that most of the wellness community
would probably get their panties in a
bunch over
and call out as toxic cancer-causing
junk the terms healthy and in contrast
unhealthy
are so subjective and it would seem to
me
that teresa's definition of healthy and
unhealthy
is rooted almost exclusively in its
caloric content
so let's talk about it from that
perspective
one of these trader joe's turkey corn
dogs has just 150 calories
which is ultimately less than like an
apple with a tablespoon of peanut butter
on top
now if we look at the nutrition label
we'll see it has
about six grams of protein and only 1.5
grams of saturated fat
so yeah nothing really to freak out
about in my books now it is higher in
preservatives like sodium
and supplies over a quarter of her
sodium needs for the day
which potentially might feel a little
bit bloating when
you know you're confined to a leotard
all day and
that number is likely to more than
double when we factor in the other
frozen meal that she has now the corn
dog is also a source of
naturally derived nitrates which may or
may not be
any less likely to contribute to cancer
risk than synthetic nitrates
but do i think that this makes this corn
dog inherently
unhealthy no not at all no
no no
no it's got carbs it's got protein and
while this
might not be the highest quality source
of these nutrients especially in
comparison to let's say that apple and
peanut butter combo
it's ultimately fine in moderation if
this is what feels good to teresa
i think this is a cutie those little
oranges maybe it's a clementine
no i usually have oranges on my break i
love oranges myself but we're looking at
like
35 calories per piece of fruit so
considering the intensity of teresa's
workout i would probably recommend
trying to get in more carbs more
calories
and again trying to keep it light and
low in fiber to prevent any digestive
distress
mid rehearsal so a fruit based smoothie
with some dates
banana maybe a bit of yogurt in there
might be a more sustaining option for a
morning snack and i actually noticed
later on in this clip
that she is having a little bit of some
kind of pre-made smoothie so
yeah that's a good option too now my
colleagues also pointed out that
getting in enough hydration is often a
challenge for dancers
just because of the annoyance of having
to get in and out of a leotard multiple
times a day
anyone who has ever worn like a cute
bodysuit to the bar
knows this dilemma well which is why i
personally mastered
the side pull and pee but anyways this
would be
a really good time to focus in on
getting in some of those fluids
so ideally about a cup of water every 20
to 30 minutes or so
and i actually noticed that i think
she's drinking like a sugar-free
gatorade here which
i mean given the intensity of her
workout may make sense to get in those
extra electrolytes
as well a woman my size just to
maintain on a normal day is roughly
1850 calories so to lose half a pound a
week
i do a 250 calorie deficit a day
which has me consuming 1604 calories a
day
so i'll be there in three weeks i'm
sorry where are these numbers coming
from
even if we were to assume that the
average five foot seven woman needs 1850
calories to sustain her weight
that would not account for the insane
amount of
intense physical activity required of a
professional ballerina
ballerinas need to be eating enough
not only to support their health but
also their rigorous training regimen
so 850 calories at baseline
is very likely not enough here a
professional ballerina teresa size
is more likely to need somewhere between
2500
to 5000 calories a day depending on the
intensity of their training
and this speaks to why it's so important
to consult with a sports dietitian
for an accurate assessment of your
unique energy needs
to promote optimal performance honestly
there
is no such calorie counting app or
online calculator
that can accurately determine what you
actually need
to help support your health and your
training having said that
you know what else is kind of annoying
if you notice people are saying
having said that after everything they
say now having said that
yes let me say this right right if we
put aside my professional stance on
teresa's goal to lose weight which is
probably that it's not in the best
interest of her health
i guess i'll give the girl props for
aiming for a relatively
realistic weight loss goal so many
people
set these lofty three to five pound a
week goals
when research suggests that slow and
steady
always wins the race and the smaller you
are to start with
the more conservative you'll want to be
to help preserve that
metabolic muscle mass and metabolism
again
i am not supporting or condoning her
weight loss goals
specifically i'm just saying that for
the general population
slower smaller weight loss goals are
obviously more likely to actually be met
so what i do is i
will just remember what i ate all day
and then at night
i have this little notebook that i put
it all into
so we had the three clementines
we're estimating that at 70. i have half
of the smoothie
okay so i am glad to see that we got a
little smoothie action in there
with her snack that's definitely gonna
make that orange snack
a lot more satiating but you know
there's definitely room to have the
whole smoothie in this scenario
oftentimes people seem to not like the
idea of counting calories
but for me it's so much easier because
otherwise you're always wondering
or you're thinking i should have seen a
result by now but if it's just
the math then you just know what's
happening and you don't have to wonder
but do you have to wonder like do you
actually
know what you're eating okay hear me out
i appreciate that for some folks
calorie counting just works whether you
need
a greater sense of control you want to
be able to eat a wider variety of foods
without worrying they're going to put
you over some
caloric allowance or you just really
like math
for some people calorie counting isn't
very triggering
but you can't tell me it's not consuming
weighing out and recording
every bite you take feels like such
a huge mental burden to me and when
you're getting down to
minute details like this is it really
precisely accurate
no not really first of all how does
teresa know
exactly what her caloric needs actually
are because
she might be able to get a super rough
guide from an online calculator but as
we already mentioned
that number does not take into
consideration intense individual
variation related to
muscle mass physical conditioning levels
metabolism
past dieting history gut microbiome and
so much more her needs are also going to
fluctuate
every single day so for one there's a
lot of assumptions being made
about her needs then we're having to put
a lot of trust in
the calorie counts that she's actually
recording so in the case of something
like an apple or really any whole food
it's important to note that the number
you see
in myfitnesspal is just an average
it's not hard absolute data
and as for processed food products note
that food manufacturers
can legally be off by 20 on their
nutrition labels
that's the difference between logging
1600 calories
and over 1900 calories in other words
it's potentially enough to derail
one's weight loss goals and we cannot
forget about
human error especially when making
estimations from
combined meals or recipes research
actually suggests that
people underestimate their true caloric
intake on average by approximately
30 so you can see why calorie counting
to this degree may be a futile
and highly inaccurate endeavor
especially when you're starting with
such a
narrow caloric window for air you know
depending on how much i danced
will influence a lot how hungry i am
since i work out so much
i'll eat over 2000 calories
but it'll still bring me in the 1600
range
so so far today i've eaten 12 25 in
calories
and so i'm going to put in my exercise
because that's going to subtract even
more off of that for when i figure out
how much i can eat
okay lots to unpack here so according to
my colleagues who actually work with
ballerinas
one of the major challenges in this
population
is that the high intensity training can
actually mask hunger
which is why what may be a better
approach in this population
is to really aim to eat balanced meals
every three to four hours and focus
mainly on
optimal pre and post training nutrition
attempting to calculate how many
calories exactly were burned in a
training session
and then plugging it in as if it makes
for like a black and white
mathematical equation is wildly
inaccurate
not to mention it's also strange to hear
her even mention
how hungry she is when she then just
goes on to determine the size of her
dinner
based on what she ate that day how many
hours she danced
and the respective calorie counts
associated with those
activities there's just a lot of mixed
messages going on
so that means i burned 804 calories
so at that point my caloric intake will
be 19.85
minus the 804 and exercise that's 11.81
so i'll probably have a big bowl of
cereal which is around 300 calories
which is 2 ounces and 200 calories
and i'll just sway it because this is
one of those things that
skim milk is 90 calories okay
well i guess in terms of balance this is
probably theresa's best meal of the day
and that is of course very important as
a post workout recovery meal
so in terms of nutrition at least we've
got you know protein in the chicken
piccata
lots of veggies in the salad and some
carbs in the cereal that she has for
dessert
but it's important to note that the
serving size on
like the package of cereal should not be
treated as a recommendation
of what you should consume rather the
serving sizes
are actually supposed to reflect what
the average person would typically
consume
but honestly some food manufacturers try
to kind of fudge this to make their
nutrition facts
look more favorable than what they
really are in real life
they're getting better but they're still
not always great
case in point nonstick cooking spray
which has a serving size
of a quarter of a second spray which is
not accurate
in my opinion so serving sizes should
therefore
not be interpreted as a recommendation
or a one
size fits all because we all have
different needs and appetites
that fluctuate day-to-day or even on an
hourly basis
so yeah i love math too but a quick and
dirty calculation
he's adding back the coefficient he has
a value for p
he's plugging that back in he takes the
derivative and he solves the equation
we'll never replace our body's innate
wisdom
even if the numbers do seem to add up i
eat pre-packaged food because
i don't have much time it's really easy
to know
what's in it and i'm not a very good
cook
i mean with all due respect i would
argue that it's easier to know what's
in your food when you make it from
whole food ingredients yourself now i
have no issues with enjoying a frozen
dinner or
a prepackaged salad or a bowl of cereal
for dinner even
like we're all busy and honestly if
leaning on some convenience food staples
helps you
nourish your body with the calories it
needs
amazing i ultimately think that that
is a good intuitive choice for self-care
so
the time convenience piece i totally get
but
choosing packaged foods because you know
what's in it
aka you have easy access to the numbers
on it
feels restrictive to me it tells me that
teresa is limiting her options to those
that she has
external data on because she's forgotten
how to access
internal data like her hunger and
fullness cues
this is definitely an area that i would
recommend theresa works on with like
a trained dietitian so that she can make
more
varied choices without compromising on
convenience or her performance i think
that people often assume that ballerinas
are maybe
hungry and they don't realize that with
exercising so much that you
can actually eat a lot of food if you
choose healthy things
yes i would agree that that is the
perception
you know that ballerinas don't eat a lot
of food and while i would say teresa's
day
does look a little more plentiful than
let's say our friend
scout foresights it's still not actually
a lot of food
one thing perhaps of note about my diet
is that i do eat from all the food
groups
you're not you're not limited i'll go
out to a restaurant and
be able to easily choose i'm not
confined to
needing to bring something along all the
time so i am happy to hear that teresa
is able to
go out to a restaurant and i guess this
is the benefit of
like a if it fits your macros or calorie
counting approach to weight loss
you know if you don't mind the enormous
mental load
that comes with logging every food you
eat and figuring out how many calories
you have left at the end of the day for
like dinner or dessert
the benefit i guess is that in some
cases
you have a bit more flexibility on the
types of food
you are allowed to eat i guess it's
different strokes for different folks
you know like all diets ultimately come
down to
some form of restriction and it just
depends on
if you want to restrict like the
quantity
versus the quality of the foods or in
some cases
both so after hiking for about an hour
and a half
then then i'll have an orange and then
i'll maybe
go and pick up a salad
okay so this seems to be like from a
different day interview is kind of all
over the place
but anyways i would say like an orange
and a low carb
low calorie salad would not be the best
choice in post-workout fuel for
cardio like a hike like that i would
definitely want to see
like a solid meal with a combination of
carbs to replenish glycogen stores
protein for muscle recovery and some
fiber and fat for
satiety so for example like a good
size sandwich with some choice of
protein in there and maybe some salad on
the side would
make for a more appropriate post-hike
meal this is what i would eat on a day
that i go
for a two-hour hike and do two hours of
stretching
this brings me to a total of 2 275
calories
and so and i've exercised just under 700
calories
so if i eat like this and exercise like
this
i'll lose a half a pound a week it's a
lot more
food than people expect i eat a lot of
vegetables and chicken and steak
fruit high fiber you know
it never ceases to amaze me how little
the internet thinks that women need to
eat
like i was shocked that in my latest
wedding a day video
that i got a ton of comments in awe
at my appetite when i'm over here
thinking that like that was actually
kind of a light day
for me so please repeat after me folks
you need more than a toddler amount of
food
to live your best life i mean i guess it
might
look like a lot of food to some people
when it's all laid out like that because
a lot of it like she mentioned is high
fiber
high volume low calorie foods like
greens
and other veg however when we think
about the general macronutrient
recommendations for dance athletes
they actually require a higher
percentage of calories
from carbohydrates in order to support
their increased
energy levels needed for training
oftentimes
my dietitian colleagues will use the
plate method
as a meal planning tool to help athletes
map out their meals to ensure that
they're actually eating enough fuel
and in the case of moderate to hard
training we would want carbohydrates to
make up
between a third and a half of your whole
plate
and that makes sense considering that
dancers train for
hours and therefore need sustained
energy
from those carbs so it might feel like
she needs to eat a high volume of foods
to meet her caloric needs because she's
mostly eating and relying on those
low calorie veggies and lean protein in
her day
but we would be able to get greater
energy nutrient bang for our buck
if we had some more carbs in there like
some more whole grains and starchy
veggies
so this is a tablespoon so one of these
with olive oil is 120 calories so if you
saw that steak i put on the scale
that was 133 calories and if you also
think
to lose half a pound a week you only
have to cut out 250 calories
you basically have to just cut out two
spoonfuls of olive oil well she seems
like a fun dinner guest
yeah there's definitely a lot of like
food fat phobic
discussion going on i noticed it also
when she was using
skim milk when i don't know in my
opinion a higher fat milk is always
going to be
a more satiating satisfying choice
but anyways teresa is of course
corrected saying that oils
are calorically dense compared to a lot
of other foods in the diet
so when you're in a caloric deficit
i'm not denying that we want to make
kind of smart decisions
about added oils and fats in our diet in
favor of
other higher fiber higher volume foods
that contain
far fewer calories but when our diet
gets down to
minute numbers like this we really miss
out on the very important enjoyment
factor
that helps us feel emotionally satisfied
from our meal
and if you're not satisfied you're
always going to be
fighting with yourself for more now fat
is
also more physically satiating as well
and is also important for promoting
better nutrient absorption
from fat soluble vitamins in things like
a salad
so my take home message for everyone
even those who are trying to lose weight
is not to fear fat a little dressing or
cooking oil can
absolutely be worked into any diet even
if you are
in a caloric deficit to try to lose
weight people often
joke about how much more i eat than they
expect when i'll go out to dinner
because i'll get a
big piece of fish and a big plate of
vegetables and
i just won't eat a lot of olive oil and
bread and that sort of thing maybe
someone who knows very little about
nutrition might think it's a lot but
when i
just see like a plain big piece of fish
and a big plate of vegetables with no
carbs or fat
my diet food alarms go off
so yeah i know i'm a professional but
she's not fooling me
so really i think that the key is
figuring out how to not
be hungry and that's actually what the
counting helps me do and i'll
talk to a friend that's on some new diet
or something and it becomes
such a big part of your focus where this
i feel like
can just run in the background so this
is really
really interesting and again i think it
really comes down to
like different things working for
different people
but remembering and physically writing
down
every single thing you eat every single
day doesn't seem to just
run in the background on its own it
does seem to be a significant commitment
physically and mentally and whether or
not she feels consumed by it i mean
is personal but i disagree that
there isn't a focus on it it's
literally a math activity that she's
having to do multiple times
a day i mean she has made it clear that
she's a very busy girl
and writing down everything she eats
physically
eats up time personally i would
way rather use that time to make
one homemade batch prepped meal for the
week
or i don't know like literally any other
act of self-care
if cooking is not like an enjoyable task
this
interview is just getting weirder
if if you're not getting the nutrition
you need
you can't keep up with the mental and
physical demands of ballet
well yeah i mean we definitely agree on
that
and it's no question that under fueling
combined with rigorous exercise or
training
can lead to serious health consequences
which go way beyond not being able to
keep up with the demands
of the sport in fact over training and
under fueling
commonly increases the risk of what we
know of
as the female athlete triad aka
increased risk of low energy
availability or intake
with or without disordered eating
impaired bone health which can increase
the risk of fractures
and reproductive suppression like
menstrual irregularity
not to mention under fueling can also
lead to
nutrient deficiencies mood changes
soft tissue damage slow recovery
weakness and mental impairment which i
can imagine would make things like
intricate choreography a bit of a
challenge
so to teresa's point getting enough fuel
in the tank
is essential for both physical and
mental health
and again that means ensuring that we're
getting enough fuel to support
basic energy needs and our training
regimen
so all that said what can we say about
teresa's diet
well i appreciate that we're not seeing
a ton of the typical
deity foods here like it's definitely
refreshing to not start the day with
lemon water
celery juice and avocado toast like
everybody else on youtube
but on the flip side we are seeing
pretty
much an exclusive reliance on highly
processed foods many of which are
microwaved from the freezer
and therefore high in preservatives and
salt and based on our rough calculations
theresa is getting about twice of the
recommended daily salt
which is probably not a huge deal
considering her electrolyte needs
are higher than the average person it
also looks like her calcium iron and
fiber
intake is a little bit lower than what
we would want to see
and since both female athlete triad
and iron deficiency are commonly
found in female athletes we would
definitely want to be
consistent in getting enough as for
macros
she's getting roughly 21 of her calories
from protein
38 of her calories from fat and 41
of her calories from carbs and while
even with this reduced
calorie intake her carb intake would
still be
too low for this sport but if we
actually were to consider that these
percentages
are based on an already hugely
suppressed caloric intake
we can see that she needs more a lot
more
of basically everything across the board
she just needs ultimately more food
so for some nutrition tips we do want to
be
super gentle in this population
especially since she has
likely been underfed all of her adult
life
so it would be really important to go
slow and focus on increasing those carbs
at meals
and snacks to slowly increase her daily
caloric
intake without triggering her to pull
back harder and restrict
we would also want to focus on nutrition
timing here
so this might look like eating a
balanced meal three to four hours before
training
an energizing pre-dance snack one to two
hours before dancing
a small high carb snack during breaks to
maintain
energy levels and then eating a
post-workout recovery meal
with a combination of protein carbs and
fat
to help replenish energy stores and
repair muscle for the following day
i would also personally want to consider
the quality of her diet
and not just quantity when it comes to
nourishment
and relying on numbers alone can't
really speak so much to that
so for a professional dancer we would
definitely want to see a greater
emphasis on meals rich in
higher fiber carbs to support energy
needs protein to support muscle recovery
as well as those healthy fats to reduce
inflammation using what we call
that dancer's plate that we already
discussed so bumping up the carbs in her
rehearsal snacks will be a really easy
way to deliver some
much needed energy and help her meet her
daily fiber needs which we already
discussed were a little bit low
lastly it's also really important to
stay hydrated
which as i mentioned can be a bit
challenging on some of those
long rehearsal days however rather than
drinking a huge amount of water in one
go
my colleague suggested drinking smaller
more frequent amounts of water
throughout before and also after
rehearsal
so this might look like drinking two to
three cups of water before rehearsal
and one cup every 20 minutes during
finally
what can we say about teresa's
relationship with food
well this is a tricky one i will say
that it was refreshing to not hear a ton
of moralizing language about food the
girl eats corn dogs
microwavable meals and other convenience
foods she doesn't restrict
dairy sugar or salt and she doesn't
label foods as inherently
good or bad she also doesn't seem to
moralize herself
around her body size or weight it all
seemed
very removed like as if her body is her
machine
and the food is just the fuel to make it
move and look a certain way
i'm not sure if that's a good thing or a
bad thing
it's not something that i would want
personally for my relationship with food
or my body but i do think it is the
default mentality for
a lot of athletes when it comes to food
however
like i've mentioned calorie counting
comes with
its limitations which is definitely
apparent
in this case as it doesn't take into
consideration the nutritional quality
and satisfaction factor from food rather
strictly counting calories reduces food
to a strict
arbitrary numbers game and that can
ultimately
make it really easy to override your
body's cues
and true needs this does seem to be the
case with teresa
as we're seeing that despite meeting her
alleged caloric requirement
she still isn't getting enough carbs or
micronutrients
and if we were to do a more accurate
appraisal of her needs
we would see that she needs a lot more
calories
and therefore even more carbs protein
and fat
to make up said calories but i do know
that the dancer's view of their energy
needs are
statistically more skewed than in other
professions so
i think it is fair to meet this dancer
where she is
and focus more on shifting those macros
for
optimal pre and post-workout fuel
ideally though i would love to see
teresa move away from strict calorie
counting
and instead attempt a combination of
some meal planning tools
and internal data just some food for
thought
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
boujee bakes for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye